al gimnasio de la escuela secundaria en
ixpal está en en Ohio llega un grupo de
ciudadanos preocupados ya en el interior
aparecieron el miedo y la ira ya que la
ciudad se ha convertido en la Zona cero
del último derrame químico tóxico en
Estados Unidos
no me siento seguro en mi ciudad
necesitamos que nuestros ciudadanos se
sientan seguros en sus propios hogares
estoy muy frustrado el 3 de febrero un
tren operado por North sodern Redwood
Company se descarriló provocando un
incendio de productos químicos
incluyendo cloruro de vinilo un
peligroso cancerígeno por temor a una
explosión mayor los funcionarios
estatales iniciaron la quema controlada
de cinco camiones cisterna enviando una
columna de humo tóxico al cielo y
obligando a la evacuación de la ciudad a
medida que los residentes regresan queda
mucho por conocerse sobre los peligros
potenciales para la salud miles de peces
murieron cuando los productos químicos
se derramaron en las vías fluviales
locales
esto es mucho grande que solo en el agua
es nuestro medio ambiente nuestros
animales salvajes nuestros agricultores
que tienen que cultivar nuestro suelo
los sindicatos dicen que las medidas
corporativas de reducción de costos
probablemente contribuyeron a una mala
distribución del peso entre los vagones
del tren y menores inspecciones de
seguridad
los representantes del ferrocarril se
negaron a asistir a una reunión con la
comunidad afectada argumentando temor a
la violencia norford ha anunciado que
creará un fondo caritativo de un millón
de dólares de ayuda el año pasado lanzó
un programa de recompra de acciones de
10 mil millones de dólares
ahora se aconseja a los residentes de
hispal está en que no beban agua del
Grifo mientras muchos temen por el
futuro de la ciudad